overwhelming majority of americans on
both sides of the political spectrum now
say the nation is quote
falling apart they're finding some
alarming new poll then some 80 percent
of democrats independents
and republicans somewhat or strongly
agree the countries disintegrating
so what's the view on the streets then
here's a snapshot
this country has been going apart
because
you know the pandemic the protesters
everything going on about the president
it's um people understand and you have
000 individuals americans dying from
coronavirus you have millions of people
unemployed you have businesses
filing for bankruptcy you have riots in
the capital you have a president
who's been impeached not once but twice
um
there is no moral compass uh in america
and we have a lot of issues between the
current president and the new president
coming
in it's not a very um i'd say
easy switch over i think that kind of
with the current that
the new president-elect biden is doing
as far as trying to impeach the ultra
the old president is kind of childish
you